Is there a good multivitimate for my family to take?
Okay, this has been a tough question for a very long time.
It's actually just recently
that I was gonna make a video of this
supplement, but I didn't
and I should make it. It's a new supplement we started carrying from aloe vea
and let me pull it up because I don't, I think it's called vitality,
let me not curl, roll, let me look it up.
And the reason why I said it's a hard question to answer
is that number one, so many supplements out there
have so many synthetic nutrients in it, which I don't like.
And then there are supplements that now, you know, about eight years ago, and
methylation came into the knowledge of the
naturopathic world, which I think was a great crime, how it's been so misused.
But then, you know, there's methylated B12, methylated folate in it,
in all the better supplements, which can be way too many methyl groups for a little kid.
And some of the other supplements out there are just garbage.
You know, they have cyanokabolamine in it for the B12, and they have, you know,
calcium carbonated, you know, I made multiple videos on how to recognize bad supplements.
And then a many of them just aren't really good for people with cancer, but you're asking,
you know, what is a good supplement for your family?
Well, aloe vera came out with a product just a couple of months ago called Vitality,
and it's really one of the first whole food supplements.
Now, there was some whole food supplements by garden of life and things,
but then garden of life got bought out by bear or something like that,
and their supplements went downhill.
So it's really hard to find a whole food supplement.
So this is one of the first whole food supplements.
I've always argued that you could just use greens first and greens first capsules for a
basically whole food nutritional source, but Vitality is a very specific supplementation that's
whole food that you could give your kids and your family, everything is from a food source,
which there's just not really any other supplements that I could recommend.
And people would ask, I just want to take a multiple, but I was on the phone with a person
of their family member. You know, I want to just take a multiple, and it's like, I don't have any
choices for you. So now we do. So it's the aloe vera Vitality.